-Our first guest tonight
is a very funny actor,
comedian, and
"Celebrity Jeopardy!" champion
you know from
"The Mindy Project,"
"Neighbors,"
and "The Afterparty."
He executive-produces and stars
in "History of the World,
Part II."
New episodes premiere daily
through March 9th on Hulu.
Let's take a look.
-Aah!
[ Door opens ]
[ Grunts ]
Sorry I'm late, but I'm here now
in my uniform.
Why don't we sign this treaty
and end this war?
Alright?
Here we go.
Right here.
Ah-ah-ah.
Bobby, you're up.
-This is truly
the most difficult thing
I have ever
been called on to do.
-Just go ahead and sign it.
-I pray that this never
happens again.
-Right next to where I put mine.
-As a boy,
my father taught me to --
-What'd he tell you?
What'd he tell you?
You got to fight with a sign
to end the war.
Huzzah!
Who wants a drink?
I do.
You want a drink?
I'm buying, I'm buying.
-Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend
Ike Barinholtz, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Great clip.
We got our friend Jack McBrayer,
little -- my brother --
-Little Josh Meyers in there.
-Yeah, very nice, very exciting.
-Yes, yes, Civil War.
Spoiler alert, the North won.
-Okay. Thank you.
Thank you
for letting everybody know.
I have so much
to talk to you about.
Now, I want to get to
"Celebrity Jeopardy!"
but I know that in order
to be considered a celebrity,
you have to be --
it has to be worldwide,
and you are now worldwide-known.
You just took a Christmas trip
to England.
-I did.
-Recognized there, as well,
I would assume.
-I was recognized throughout
England, throughout France.
-Wow.
-I now call myself
Mr. Worldwide, like Pitbull.
[ Laughter ]
-Does Pitbull know?
-No, he does not know, and don't
tell him, guys, seriously.
Don't, like, tag, snitch me.
So we went to England for --
We were there for the holidays.
Right? And we were there
Christmas Day.
English Christmas is lovely.
You go, you put your roast in,
then you go to a bar.
-Great.
-Because there's a lot
of alcoholics out there.
-Yeah, yeah.
-So we went
to this beautiful pub,
and there was
all these people there,
and we're in Richmond,
where "Ted Lasso" takes place.
You're overlooking
the beautiful village green.
It's gorgeous.
-That's great.
And you were with family?
-I was with my wife's
entire family, okay?
I'm Jewish.
My wife's not.
So her Christian family and me
in England,
but I feel comfortable.
-Yeah, although it's weird,
'cause you're making
a very clear distinction.
-Yes. Yeah, no,
I swear, it was great.
And we're there,
and we're outside,
and this British woman
comes up to me.
Like I said,
I'd been getting recognized.
-Yeah, Mr. Worldwide.
-Mr. Worldwide.
And she kind of, you know,
has that smile on her face,
and she's holding her phone,
which is turned to the camera.
She's kind of looking at me.
And I was like, "Picture?"
She goes, "Yeah."
And I go, "What's your name?"
And she's like, "Pat."
And I'm like, "Hello, Pat.
I'm Ike," and I grab it
and I put my arm around her
and I get into selfie mode.
I'm like, "Are you having
a good Christmas?"
She's like, "Yeah."
I'm like, "Let's get one.
Let's get a fun one."
You know,
and I give it back to her.
I'm like, "Thank you, Pat.
Have a great Christmas."
She goes, "Thank you.
Will you take a photo of me
and my family, please?"
[ Laughter ]
And...
as my brain is processing
what's happening,
just like six degrees
to the right,
my wife is crying, like,
the hardest she's ever laughed.
Runs over
to her whole family like,
"You're not going to believe
what just happened."
So the rest of the trip,
like, the nephews are like,
"Hey, remember
when that lady..."
And I'm like, "Yeah."
-Also, it really --
It shows you that the politeness
of the British people
can do a great disservice,
'cause any other country,
they'd be like,
"No, no, not with you."
-"Who are you?
No, no, no, no."
-But she let you go through
with two photos.
You did the fun one.
-And a fun one.
-Yeah.
-So embarrassing.
She's going to, like,
someday see something I'm in
and be like, "Oh, he took
a photo with me once.
Remember that weirdo in the park
on Christmas?"
-That'll be fun, too.
She'll be like,
"Here he is being serious,
and here's his fun one."
But look, you know what?
All jokes aside,
congratulations, my friend.
You did it.
-Oh, look at that.
-You did it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Right there.
-I mean, I --
I spent a couple summers
where I fully was
a roommate of yours,
and I know you to be a guy
who would come home every day,
watch "Jeopardy!", yell out the
answers before the contestants.
-Yes, very annoying.
-And a lot of people do that,
and it's very annoying
and it goes nowhere,
and they live sad lives,
and yet you're, like,
the one guy
where you basically can turn
around and just flip us all off
and be like,
"See, I was studying!"
-Celebrity champion!
Celebrity champion!
Yeah, it was amazing.
-Were you nervous
about your competition?
-I was pretty nervous.
There were a couple names
on the list of celebs.
Our good friend Brendan Hunt.
-Yeah, from "Ted Lasso."
-From "Ted Lasso," was
very worried about playing him.
Patton Oswalt, I was
-Very heady,
very smart gentleman.
-Very smart guy,
and it came down, basically,
to me and him in the finals,
and I beat him by $1.
-That's very exciting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, you go on, correct --
Now, I didn't realize this.
You play in the Tournament
of Champions with regular --
-Yes, the non-celebrities.
-'Cause I won
celebrity poker once,
and people always would say,
"Oh, that's so impressive."
And I'm saying,
you have to remember,
when you put "celebrity"
in front of a contest,
it's a way of saying worse.
-Yes.
-Are you worried about this one,
or you just kind of go in
knowing you have no chance?
-Oh, I'm terrified.
I'm going to get my ass
absolutely handed to me
by just --
I have no plan.
I would try to bully them,
but that won't work.
And I'm just going to get
destroyed, and I can't wait.
I can't wait.
-I hope -- You know what?
I hope that night
is the first time
that woman whose picture
you took sees you.
-[ British accent ]
Oh, God. The guy --
That bloke with the -$2,000,
look, look at the fun one.
-[ British accent ]
He always thinks he's there
for the wrong thing.
[ Normal voice] I want to ask
about "History of the World."
We'll be right back with more
from Ike Barinholtz.